[Music]
make sure your parents sign these i'll
need them back by friday
mr cooper you're late i know i'm late my
training wheel's broke
training wheels yes derek i have
training wheels like a child i also have
a job like an adult i'm a very
complicated person
sure let's go with complicated okay
permission slips
what's in the mug it's a coffee mug tam
what do you think is in it
could be soup it's coffee where'd you
get it
the teacher's lounge and before you ask
no i'm not the world's greatest grandpa
says when do you drink coffee i don't
but this job is killing me you wouldn't
understand
you realize i have a job at your parents
convenience store that doesn't count
why not you get to sit at a cash
register and have the fun of doing math
ashley the cash register tells you how
much change to give
oh that's too bad
oh i hear they're opening an olive
garden where the old sizzler used to be
on hampton road yeah i think that was a
sizzler that was a
cheat cheese no the chichis is on
bedford across from the payless shoes
she's right because one time we got
shoes and then we got cheat cheese
that was a good day huh i guess that was
a sizzler
i'm sorry they closed that oh there's
still the other one on route 40. who
cares
you have a problem yes i do i've had a
long day is it too much to ask for a
dinner with a little peace and quiet
sheldon you do not talk to your father
like that fine i'd rather not speak to
any of you
maybe i better go talk to him no i got
this george maybe you should calm down
first
i got this
you won't explain yourself i'd rather
just go to bed since i have to be up in
a few hours anyway
look i understand you're tired but that
is no reason i'm not just tired
i'm exhausted everything hurts i get up
in the morning to do this job i don't
even like
and i'm doing it just for the money and
it's not even a lot of money
i keep trying harder and harder and it
doesn't even make a difference
so if you're going to yell at me or
punish me let's just get it over with
am i going to punish you why not i
deserve it
let me tell you about my day i got
yelled at by the principal for benching
a linebacker who's flunking english then
i got yelled at even more by the kid's
parents
then i had to break up a fight in the
locker room got elbow in the neck
that's a rough day that was all before
10 a.m
so i get what you're going through but
you'll notice i didn't come home and
take it out on you
no you didn't now once you get back in
there
apologize to everyone and finish your
dinner
yes sir
[Music]
my father's wisdom touched me deeply
which is why to this day no matter what
i'm going through
i am never irritating or abusive to any
of my friends or loved ones
ask them they'll tell you
[Music]
for the next several months i continued
working my paper route
until i paid my father back
[Music]
do
so
you